[Music]
in munich this was the welcoming party
for some of the most powerful leaders on
the planet
for the next few days germany will host
the g7 meeting of the world's richest
nations
and protesters came marked with demands
i've come here because the politics of
the g7 countries
are um
injust and in transparent what's your
message to the g7 leaders
g7 make private predators cancel the
death of the global south
these men have the cash and the power
for this year an even heavier
responsibility
when germany first planned this meeting
it was heavily focused on climate change
but then russia invaded ukraine and now
those leaders have other challenges to
contend with including war
food shortages and energy security
[Music]
some here fear leaders are putting
energy ahead of environment as supplies
is squeezed russia's recent reduction of
gas to germany means it's one of the
countries where coal will help to fill
the gap
i'm very concerned that this summit is
used by the g7 leaders
to amplify the effort to go into fossil
energy
but the answer to putin must be to phase
out fossil fuels as soon as possible and
to enter into phase with renewable
energies and more solidarity around the
globe others simply worry so much power
is held in the hands of so few
i'm here because i think that the g7 is
a club of very little
rich but powerful people and they do not
have the right to put their standards
all over the world
when tension did bubble over it was
brief and quickly contained
something the g7 leaders will hope for
as they prepare to discuss the numerous
crises now facing the world siobhan
robbins sky news